j'ai envie de tranquillité de tous et
paysages
divers surtout vis-à-vis du coup chef de
jaar mao
pierre la branche a les nerfs en boule
parce que dit-il
ses voisines font trop de bruit la nuit
ses voisines ce sont les éoliennes du
parc des moulins les plus proches sont
situés à moins d'un kilomètre de sa
maison et donc de sa chambre des coûts
chez tacca chavire toujours a dit
pourquoi dans le vin fait le moins
d'erreurs jeunes pop tower seul recours
pierre la branche fait partie d'un
groupe de citoyens des appalaches qui
demande à la cour d'autoriser un recours
collectif contre les promoteurs du parc
des moulins
il s'inspire d'un autre groupe de
citoyens du centre du québec qui a il y
a quelques mois obtenu le feu vert pour
intenter un recours collectif contre les
propriétaires du parc éolien de l'érable
une première au québec quand tu dis
qu'en ville
si voisins même trop de bruits formule 1
est ce qu ils vont dire à personne nous
aurons atteint solo voor een uccle la
fois au coeur de l'argumentaire des
plaignants se trouve un concept légal
très simple le trouble de voisinage
la loi dit que les voisins doivent
accepter les inconvénients normaux du
voisinage
ce qui sous-entend qu'il y a aussi des
inconvénients de voisinage anormaux
cette notion est au coeur de la cause
ciment st laurent
en 2008 la cour suprême du canada
ordonne à la cimenterie de beauport de
dédommager ses voisins pour le bruit et
la poussière qui s'est accumulée dans
leur maison le jugement du plus haut
tribunal du pays stipule que même sans
avoir commis de faute
une entreprise qui causent des
inconvénients anormaux en est
responsable
les eaux qui vont suivre après nous y
aurons enfin je vous prie dans ce bureau
une compagnie qui va pouvoir nous faire
chier comme ils nous ont fait chier et
en effet c'est cette jurisprudence qui
sept ans après laffaire ciment
saint-laurent sera invoquée par les
avocats des voisins des parcs éoliens
on se pince au far west est un acquis on
est obligé de fait une haie calignac
pour faire nettoyer l'intérieur
maison c'était affreux on avait coché
pas 2,3 et éviter le recours collectif y
touche associe tout ce qu'on a enduré
pendant la construction de ce projet
nous c'était l'enfer
une des clés disaient que ça ne veut pas
de train mais c'est pas vraiment
et voici le bruit que ça fait une
éolienne ça peut être plus ou moins fort
selon la force du vent le recours
collectif demande donc le versement de
compensations en dommages et intérêts
pour perte de jouissance notamment à
cause du bruit pour l'heure brûlot belle
aux sabots pour combler une compagnie
indépendante parce que là dessus sur
l'autre les autres nous disent leur que
ça rentre dans le nord ce qui va se
passer à saint ferdinand ou à saint jean
de brébeuf et intéressant pour tout le
monde
puisqu'il faut prouver c'est dommage et
donc faire des études plus poussées que
ce qui existe déjà
donc on a utilisé jusqu'ici cd mesure
générale portant sur des grandes
populations en faisant des moyennes et à
partir de moyenne on ne trouve rien et
on ne démontre rien alors que les
méthodologies qui devrait probablement
être utilisés dans ces cas là sont des
méthodologies beaucoup plus pointu qui
vont examiner le problème chez telle et
telle et telle famille telle et telle
maison et donc on serait davantage en
mesure de mieux mesurer de mieux mesurer
l'impact réel
c'est comme sauver une personne en
détresse qui voit pas trop foot nous
c'est nos propriétés qu'on veut sauver
au delà des nuisances c'est aussi la
dévaluation des propriétés qu'il va
falloir démontrer comme chez yvan
bourque qui croient que personne ne
voudra acheter sa maison maintenant que
22 éoliennes se trouve autour
pourtant dès 2010 le bureau d'audiences
publiques en environnement demandé au
ministère des affaires municipales
d'étudier l'impact des éoliennes sont la
valeur marchande des propriétés
cinq ans plus tard le ministère nous dit
qu'une grille d'analysé devraient être
prêtes cette année il paraît que ça
ferait comme tout les projets éoliens
ils vont stagner des travaux d'eau par
heure sauf avons refait dans les forêts
grand octobre rapporte repos et se
vendre sa part dans l'histoire par la
taille grand caractère
l'industrie éolienne est une affaire de
gros sous
des revenus garantis de millions de
dollars pour les exploitants des
redevances pour les municipalités et les
propriétaires qui acceptent les
éoliennes sur leur terrain ces recours
collectif pourrait maintenant forcer
l'industrie à tenir compte de ceux qui
subissent les inconvénients sans en
retirer les profits c'est le cas en
france ou en 2013
un juge est allé jusqu'à ordonner la
destruction des éoliennes qui gâchaient
le paysage de ce château la sphère et en
appel